Digital technologies and social media
have fundamentally reshaped
political and civic participation.
The public, especially
the younger generation,
demand greater involvement
in decision-making.
They want a chance
to shape policy
and in a way that goes beyond
voting in elections
every 5 years.
The European Parliament,
the Council
and the European Commission
have heard this call.
Our response is the Conference
on the Future of Europe.
The Conference is a citizen-focused,
bottom-up democratic exercise.
It gives people the chance to influence
how the EU works for them.
A key feature of the Conference
will be the European Citizens’ Panels.
800 Europeans from the 27 EU Member States
are randomly selected.
They are sorted into four panels
of 200 people each –
Each panel is representative
of the EU’s diversity
in terms of age, gender,
geographic origin,
level of education
and socio-economic background.
Young people between 16 and 25 will make up
one third of each panel.
Then they will get to work
discussing the big topics
that EU citizens care about.
These topics will be chosen by citizens –
an innovative multilingual
digital platform
has been set up to gather views.
People around Europe can submit
and debate ideas
and issues using the platform –
and the outcomes will inspire
the discussions of the panels.
With the assistance of facilitators
and expert insights,
the panels will meet
and deliberate together.
This will take place in 24 EU languages,
during three sessions of two days each.
The panel members will be asked
to work together,
discuss, and ultimately
form recommendations.
Representatives from each panel
will then present the outcome
of their discussions to the Plenary,
and debate them
with other participants.
And then the EU institutions
will need to follow up
This is the commitment we have made.
This is one of the most ambitious
citizens’ consultation exercises
ever undertaken.
The EU is embarking on an exciting path
of true democratic innovation
aimed at strengthening our
representative democracy –
and these multilingual, pan-European panels
are one of the most exciting parts of it!